bonsoir à savage il ya plusieurs années
je vais en italie je venais de me marier
avec mon mari est français et ensemble
nous avons déménagé dans une superbe
petite ville proche de ville ive
un jour j'ai regardé les infos et les
journalistes annoncer les résultats d'un
sondage intrigant dé quoi les enfants et
callian avait-il et plus peur des kwh
aviez-vous le plus peur quand vous étiez
petit et bien ceux dont les enfants
italiens avaient le plus peur je n'étais
pas de perdre leurs parents ni de se
perdre ni du noir ce qu'ils craignaient
les plus c'était les extras comme en
italie
les immigrants de l'extérieur de l'union
européenne les enfants en italie avaient
plus peur des immigrants qui est du
traditionnel père fouettard et tout d'un
coup je me suis rendu compte que moi
même j'étais in extra communautaire
puisque je suis brésilien
il se trouve qu'à ces moments là j'ai
déjà mémoire sur l'immigration et des
nombreuses études démontraient l'impact
positif de l'immigration sur l'économie
italienne
je me suis dit comment une chose aussi
positive d'un point de vue strictement
rationnelle peut-elle être perçu comme
étant une chose aussi négative d'un
point de vue émotionnel des puis je suis
fasciné par les rapports des êtres
humains à la différence et au cours de
ma vie professionnelle j'ai remarqué que
ce sont souvent les personnes les plus
différentes des mois qui m'ont le plus
fait grandir et c'est ainsi que je suis
devenu
madame diversité la diversité c'est le
mélange des différences humaines visible
et invisible
il ya des différences qui sont assez
évidentes comme celles liées au genre à
l'âge aux origines il ya des différences
qui sont tous utiles comme celles liées
aux différents types de personnalités
comme ceux liés aux différentes qui
d'orientation sexuelle à certains types
de handicap
l'inclusion c'est une culture dans
laquelle on se sent valorisé est libre
d'être soi même
même quand on est différent de la
majorité
la diversité et l'inclusion
mais il faut penser à la bonne cuisine
[Musique]
la diversité ce sont les ingrédients et
l'inclusion c'est la recette pour
mélanger les ingrédients d telle sorte
qu'ils aient résultat final soit un plat
délicieux dans lesquelles les
ingrédients se marie bien tout en
révélant leurs meilleures saveurs et
dans les entreprises
j'ai trouvé un paradoxe similaire à
celui de l'italie des nombreuses études
montrent que la diversité et l'inclusion
peuvent améliorer les ventes
la motivation la productivité
l'innovation et même les résultats
financiers des entreprises par exemple
-selon catalyst les entreprises avec
plus des femmes dans les postes de
direction sont en moyenne 34 % plus
rentable selon mme acquise et les
entreprises avec plus de diversités
ethniques sont en moyenne 35% plus
profitable pourtant les entreprises ont
beaucoup de mal à avancer dans ces
domaines pourquoi souvent on évoque la
culture d'entreprise comme étant l'un
des facteurs qui empêchent les
entreprises
dd promouvoir la diversité et
l'inclusion un des obstacles majeurs
mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une culture d'entreprise dit
simplement une culture d'entreprise
c'est la façon dont les gens
interagissent au sein d'une organisation
donné il n'y a pas des cultures
d'entreprises en dehors des personnes
qui la font pourtant j'ai interviewé des
milliers des collaborateurs et des
salariés des personnes dans 17 dans
différents secteurs différents pays et
souvent que les gens parlent de leur
culture d'entreprise
il en parle comme si c'était quelque
chose de séparé d'eux mêmes comme si j'y
étais pour rien
en ce qui concerne la diversité et
l'inclusion quand j'ai des mois de
collaborateurs qu'est ce que vous faites
vous pour contribuer à un environnement
de travail plus ouverts à tous ils me
disent ah vous voir ça avec les managers
je vois les managers je leur pose la
même question aimez les pompes à vous
voir ça avec la direction
je vais voir les directeurs et qu'est ce
qu'il me dit de votre avis très bonne
question pour voir ça avec la direction
des ressources humaines et vous savez ce
qu'ils me disent souvent mais direction
des ressources humaines
1 cela dépend vraiment vraiment du
management et ainsi de suite
la vérité c'est qu'il ya une chaîne des
responsabilités
personne ne peut à lui tout seul crée
une culture inclusive mais chacun
d'entre nous un rôle à jouer car nous
avons tous une zone d'influencé
alors bien sûr plus vous avez des
responsabilités plus cette zone
d'influencé est importante mais chacun
d'entre nous un hymne zone d' influence
ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
ce sont deux actions simples à la portée
de tous pour favoriser la diversité et
l'inclusion en entreprise
deux actions qui vous pouvait prendre
dans n'importe quelle organisation et
quel que soit votre statut
deux actions qui feront de votre lieu de
travail un endroit bien plus
enrichissantes et agréable à vivre pour
tous et surtout pour vous même la
première action et ses passes de votre
tête et elle consiste à dépasser vos
premières impressions
savez vous combien de temps il faut pour
se former une opinion sur un inconnu un
dixième de seconde
inconsciemment nous classons les
personnes de manière automatique utilisé
des critères facilement observables
comme la taille la couleur de la peau le
sexe l'âge 7 mécanisme des
catégorisations nous permet même aux
aides à faire face à la complexité du
monde mais il est aussi à l'origine des
préjugés
nous aimerions tous pour la plupart
d'entre nous ne pas avoir de préjugés
n'est ce pas c'est peut-être notre
intention un niveau conscient mais notre
inconscient qui dictent nos
comportements 95% du temps lui il est
tout le temps en train de juger les gens
sur des apparences qui peuvent être
trompeuses et personne n'est à l'abri
une fois j'ai parlé avec une
réceptionniste qui était mal voyantes et
elle me disait que même elle pouvait
juger les gens avant de les connaître en
fonction du temps de leur voix
l'université de harvard a mis au point
un outil incroyable ça s'appelle le test
d'associations implicite
qui permet de mesurer nos préjugés
inconscient ou comme les dix très
joliment les scientifiques nos billets
sont conscients dans différentes
catégories
par exemple vous pouvez mesurer si vous
avez ou non des biens inconscient
négatives ou positives d'ailleurs envers
les gens en fonction de leur poids en
fonction de leur âge et justement vous
attendez un instant
est-ce que vous m'écoutez y est
différemment
ils étaient plus âgés
saviez vous que selon les groupes de
recherche orages
l'âge est le premier facteur de
discrimination en europe
ici j'étais ici j'étais noir est-ce que
vous m'écoutez y ait de la même façon
peut-être que si j'étais moi je ne
serais même pas la salle et pourquoi
selon l'observatoire des discriminations
en france
ac v et gagnent une personne avec un nom
africain à 3 fois moins des chances de
se faire embaucher qui nous personne
avec un non européen leur maintenant
est-ce qui vous m'écoutez y ait de la
même façon si j'étais un homme
logé un style vous avez dû remarquer
j'ai un style de communication qui est
très doux qui l'on retrouve plus
fréquemment chez les femmes et de nos
sociétés
on confond souvent douceur et faiblesses
et c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles les femmes sont moins choisis
pour les postes de direction une fois
j'avais un chef américain qui m'appelait
qui m'a dit tu as his j'ai besoin de
parler vu peur mais il m'a regardé droit
dans les yeux et il m'a dit je voulais
m'excuser auprès de toi car quand
j'étais embauché
j'avais beaucoup de doutes sur sa
capacité à mener notre stratégie tu
avais l'air trop gentille et le temps
m'a montré à quel point je me suis
trompé sur tes capacités mon ancien chef
lui il a su dépasser les primes ses
premières impressions et il m'a donné
une chance la chance de les surprendre
il apparaît évident n'est-ce pas mais
dites moi vous c'est quand la dernière
fois que vous avez dépassé vos premières
impressions et que vous avez donné une
chance à quelqu'un la chance de vous
surprendre
autrement dit c'est quand la dernière
fois qu'ils vous avez remarqué la petite
voix critiques dans votre tête et que
vous n'avez pas suivi ne l'avait pas
suivi leur passons à la deuxième action
celle ci est externe et elle consiste à
aller à la rencontre des gens qui ne
voulaient semble pas inconsciemment nous
balayons constamment l'environnement à
la recherche des signes de danger
cela fait partie de notre instinct de
survie
mais c'est aussi à cause de celle en qui
nous avons une tendance à voir les
personnes différentes de nous dont
conduit inconscient allez voir
comme de menace et donc nous avons
tendance à nous mettre en relation avec
les gens qui sont comme nous du milieu
socioéconomique des avec les mêmes
origines le même goût que nous et ainsi
de suite
c'est ce que les scientifiques appellent
le biais d'infinité et tout le monde à
ce sujet au gua d'affinités moi y
compris
une fois je suis allé dans une
convention des cadres dirigeants de
laquelle il y avait beaucoup d'autres
et petit à petit ça mais rendre compte
je me suis rapproché des rares femmes
présentes et au bout d'un moment toutes
les femmes se sont retrouvés ensemble on
comprend que cela puisse arriver de
temps en temps mais à répétition ça peut
être très nuisible personnellement ma
plus grande expérience d'inclusion et
d'appartenance à l'entreprise fait
passer dans un endroit où les gens ils
venaient vers moi et me connaissaient
pas forcément est passé mais du bon jour
mais invité à prendre un café à deux
génies ensemble et c'était des collègues
très différent de moi y pouvait être
plus jeunes plus âgés ils venaient
d'autres départements il avait d'autres
niveaux hiérarchiques mois
l'inclusion elle se concrétise dans ces
petits moments d'interaction de la vie
de tous les jours
certaines entreprises essayent dé
favoriser ces échanges qui sont source
de bien-être et d'innovation par exemple
pixar chez pixar les toilettes s'est
trouvé un emplacement central savez
pourquoi
pour que les collaborateurs de tous
horizons convergent vers un même endroit
et ses rencontres il ya des grands
groupes qui utilisent des applications
mobiles pour mettre en relation les
collaborateurs à la recherche des
collègues pour aller déjeuner mais rien
ne peut remplacer votre volonté d'aller
vers les gens
ça paraît évident n'est-ce pas mais
dites moi c'est quand la dernière fois
qui vous avait deux jeunes et avec un
collègue qui vous ne connaissiez pas
très bien c'est quand la dernière fois
que vous avez un
mais la conversation avec quelqu'un de
différent dans votre lieu de travail et
que vous voyez quelqu'un des nouveaux
des différents qu'est ce que vous faites
pour que cette personne se sente la
bienvenue dépassez vos premières
impressions et aller à la rencontre des
personnes qui ne vous ressemble pas ce
deux actions l'une inter dans l'autre
externe
elles sont simples on très simple mais
elles ne sont pas faciles car elle nous
demande d débrancher notre pilote
automatique et d sortir de notre zone de
confort mais ensemble ces deux actions
peuvent est programmé notre cerveau
élargir notre zone de confort et même
écouter bien elles peuvent le rendre
plus intelligent et plus créatif selon
des chercheurs de l'université de
columbia avant d'évoquer t je vous
propose de faire des choses très
concrètes
la première c'est d'aller sur google et
d'étapes et harvard test d'associations
implicite et des faits un test dans la
catégorie de votre choix vous allez être
surpris
et la deuxième chose toute simple c'est
d'inviter un collègue que vous ne
connaissez pas très bien à prendre un
café
les enfants italiens
ils ont peut-être entendu leurs parents
dire ne parle aux parts à des inconnus
en tant qu'adulte nous devons faire
exactement le contraire parler à des
inconnus
car comme l'a si bien dit victor hugo le
bonheur c'est cache parfois dans
l'inconnu
merci
[Applaudissements]